this is just asking questions a show for
inquiring minds on
reason today Liz wolf and I are joined
by our colleague Matt Welch editor at
large at reason and podcaster on the
reason Roundtable and the fifth column
with Camille Foster and Michael moan
he's going to help us break down the
recent Iowa caucus results and talk
about what it means for the election
going forward we also want to discuss
where Libertarians and independents
might be leaning at this point in the
presidential race and also want to talk
about some of the increasingly glaring
divides within
libertarianism that have led to
different factions pursuing very
different strategies and hold widely
Divergent views of political camp
candidates like Trump be ramaswami Ronda
santis and Nikki Haley Matt thank you
for talking with us thanks and uh for
bringing me into the uh the Fantastic
jaq Den I appreciate it the den of Jack
asy if you
will so let's bring up uh this is uh the
this is from NPR these are the results
from the Iowa caucus we see Trump took
51% of the vote to santis about 21%
Haley third place 19% the
7.7% and ASA Hutchinson with 0.2% of the
vote um where does that leave the race
at this point in your estimation Matt
that was as good of a result for Donald
Trump as he could have possibly expected
uh which is yes it's sort of confirmed
that he has more than 50% a little bit
more than 50% of the votee at least in
Iowa but also that it was close between
Nikki Haley and Ronda santz and even
that Des santz was ahead is good for
Trump because it keeps
DeSantis uh more in the race than he
might have otherwise been if Nikki Haley
would have you know somehow gotten 30%
and Des santis 15 he probably would have
dropped out of the race and making it
more of a twoh human race in New
Hampshire and that's not the case so
that's a that's great and then Vic ramas
Swami drops out immediately and uh
officially becomes Trump's mini me on
the campaign Trail uh and that's helpful
for him too so it was uh it was as good
as it can be for Donald Trump I think
what you have to look at this race right
now and
realize is that it's gonna be probably
over in five weeks or at least the next
five weeks will be determinative you
have New Hampshire next week uh and then
you have South Carolina on February 24th
I believe it is uh and that's Nikki
Haley's home state of course um New
Hampshire it is she needs to win um she
needs to win something at some point New
Hampshire has one of the most
independent electorates it's easier for
Democrats to come over and do
Shenanigans and vote in places New
Hampshire's also prickly and doesn't
like to be told by Iowa what to do we'
had the first poll that came out today
the post Vic and Chris Christie dropping
out because remember Chris Christie was
polling like 11% in New Hampshire um and
this is Boston Globe suff suffk uh and
it had Trump at 50 Nikki Haley at 34 and
Ronda s at five um and if you look at
the same poll back in September Trump
said 49 you know like it I I think it's
it's fascinating uh one of the most
interesting polls in this entire uh
season was one done by Fair vote right
the ranked Choice people and this is I
don't know four four months ago or
something like that they took when the
field was still wide they took uh all of
the candidates and they made everyone do
rank choice of them and so what you find
is that Donald Trump is the First Choice
by nearly half of the Republican
electric he's also the Last Choice by
nearly half of the Republican electric
so like I forget exactly what the number
was but like he started out like at 47%
and then rank Choice after you vote you
know the loser on the island gets kicked
off and then that person's votes uh gets
sort of a portion and keeps going Trump
couldn't get over 50% until it was just
him and Nicki Haley at the end
right because people kept ranking him
last he's a polarizing figure even
within the Republican party let alone
the rest of the country so uh Nikki
Haley has really wanted this to be a
two-person race it's still not and
that's going to be a little bit
difficult for her um she needs to win
either New Hampshire and or South
Carolina her home state if she can't win
South Carolina then what is she even
doing and this would be the only other
mode for her to get in uh if she indeed
loses uh in those next two which I think
is still the likeliest scenario although
I think there's some hope that she might
win for her uh in New Hampshire uh the
other scenario is just that she comes in
second place and something weird happens
to Trump like I don't know he gets
arrested and not arrested but he gets he
gets convicted and he's in prison and
that affects the way that Republicans
vote or I don't know what it creates
some kind of dynamic and she's the one
left with the second most number of
delegates but basically you know the
Iowa confirmed that it is Donald Trump's
party until we find out otherwise well
so in 2016 Donald Trump didn't win the
Iowa caucuses right that was Ted Cruz
what does his win this time by 51% tell
us about this race and how this looks a
little different than 2016 we've never
seen anything like this in the Iowa
Caucasus which have been going since
1976 uh people who on when there's not
an incumbent Republic Republican
president uh these caucuses are close
like the biggest margin of Victory
before this week was in 1988 when uh I
believe it was Bob do the not eventual
nominee beat Pat Robertson also the not
eventual nominee by like 12 percentage
points Trump wins by 30 that's just kind
of huge uh so it tells us that the
Republican electorate is treating Trump
like a quas incumbent um and uh and
that has remained the case for a long
time we've never seen in a contested
primary Harry enton from CNN pointed
this out earlier this week before the
Iowa vote uh we've never seen uh in a
non-incumbent race uh a a republican
treated so much like an incumbent so
it's his to lose well why should we be
giving Iowans this much power in the
first place Matt Welch have we have we
Liz I'm not sure um like like uh you
know it's the it's the perennial case of
boy these early states have a lot of
power then they all jockey for various
positions and and whatnot um these are
the people who gave us tomato beer and
ham balls right like do we really trust
these people with all of their strange
cultural proclivities they haven't
picked winners of the seven times that
we've had
non-incumbents presidents running in
Iowa they've picked the winner twice so
uh it's I remember president Santorum it
was a a great president hucke yeah I
mean actually Ron Paul came came within
an eyelash and there was some uh like
interpretation that he actually came in
first but by the time they figured that
out it was several months too late so no
it's not necessarily predictive but
that's just a huge margin and there's a
lot of copium being uh drank by people
who don't want Trump trying to talk
themselves out of what looks like it's
his to lose unless you know uh unless
there's a New Hampshire miracle I do
think that people are overreacting a
little little bit or they're they're
precluding the possibility of New
Hampshire uh doing the New Hampshire
thing it's still a possibility and you
know Nikki Haley has has uh narrowed the
the margin by a lot in a short period of
time there so who knows I say I assume
that the the game I I assume like the
the game theory here is like there's all
the incentives for DeSantis and Haley to
hang in there right because of that X
Factor of Trump's you know legal
troubles I guess it's
it's going to coincide with super
Tuesday uh one of the cases um is that
your expectation that uh you know
they're just gonna hang in there just on
that no matter what happens just on that
off chance that someone's got to be the
nominee D santis his demeanor reminds me
a lot of Rand Paul's demeanor in
2015 and 16 in the sense that ramp Paul
was not having fun and you could tell
like uh at some point we forget this now
but in 2014 kind of in the the
prehistory of that election Rand Paul
was a front runner he was frequently
ahead in polls and he seemed to have the
wind at his sailes it was we were living
through the libertarian moment the micro
moment when Liz wolf was in diapers um
it had a Rand Paul t-shirt and I must
say there's like some adorable photo of
me from like my college days with like
all my Rand Paul gear on so I'll have to
R oh I stood I stood with r there's a
lot of standing with randing at CPAC and
and elsewhere uh but like he just had a
miserable time he was not having fun
DeSantis you can tell he's not I mean
he's just uh Zach you know him a lot
better as uh as your Governor as
America's governor down in Florida but
like uh he has I think even a different
demeanor as Governor than he does as a
presidential candidate and there's been
a lot of reporting coming out just like
that I mean they they blew through a ton
of money they bet it all on Iowa and he
barely squeaked one out against Nicki
Haley he's polling right now that same
poll has met five %c the Boston Globe
suffle poll and and you know that's
after they've wiped out Vic and Chris
Christie um so who knows whether I you
know if he gets 5% of the vote in New
Hampshire that's an awful uh that's an
awful low amount to get excited about
campaigning for another three weeks I
think it's plausible that he drops out
then I mean it must be really hard
stuffing his feet into those uh cowboy
boots with lifts every single day you
know I can understand feeling a little
exhausted by all of that if you're use
them to dance a little bit like some
Cuban heels there's no problem at all
but if it's just like I want to be
taller then that's no good poor man uh I
do want to understand Matt you've been
studying the libertarian party in all of
its different incarnations for many many
years now where do you think
Libertarians are likely to Cluster now
given the sort of weird and changing
presidential field uh we have no idea
and it's also like small L and capital L
are different things I mean small l
libert Libertarians like those of us
with libertarian Persuasions who may or
may not be myed by the direction of the
lp the it's funny you know I the people
who know about the direction of the lp
right who know about the mises caucus uh
self-described takeover that happened
that Zach covered so well um in the past
and and in an ongoing basis really um
that is known by People Like Us who are
very online Libertarians I'm not sure
that it's known by the 750,000 Americans
who were registered as Libertarians
which is by the way three times the
number as it was 20 years ago um which
is pretty significant Libertarians are
on a uh three presidential election
bronze medal streak uh which is
definitely a tallest dwarf category
situation but also like we haven't seen
any party do that since the 19th century
when it was the Socialists um so by far
they will have the most uh uh
presidential ballot access of any third
party um it's remains to be seen what
happens with Robert F Kennedy Jr um and
how many ballots he gets he's doing a
mix of his own name and and like
hijacking or creating other parties to
get on there and I think all of that is
one of the um the most underrated part
of this uh campaign I I presume that
we're going to see a lot more thought
and activity about that in the very near
future certainly um uh depending on what
happens to Nikki Haley in the next two
main uh uh primaries Nevada has a caucus
and she's not even competing um but uh
there there is such a huge sentiment
Robert of Kenny Jor is polling at 15% uh
that's crazy we haven't seen that from
an independent since Ross perau um you
still have Dean Phillips and MaryAnn
Williamson uh polling combined above 10%
against Joe Biden and no one's paying
any attention to them at all um there's
even an outside chance that Dean
Phillips might uh might be a thorn in
Biden's Side in New Hampshire it's all
weird with ran stuff there's all this uh
ferment happening Americans hate this
election and they have from the
beginning and it's it's now looking even
more like the thing that they've wanted
to hate both Biden and Trump are
underwater among Independents who were
always the Swing Vote in presidential
elections um Biden won last time and
people tend to forget this he won
because the people who voted third party
in 2016 uh the majority of whom were
Libertarians voting or at least voted
Libertarians uh he won because those
people didn't vote for third party they
voted for him um the the percentage of
the third party vote in 2016 was
5.7 uh in uh 2020 was 1.8 and what did
the Democrat do uh compared to Hillary
Hillary Clinton he went up by three
percentage points so it's pretty clear
that's what happened people freaked out
about Trump they didn't like him
Independence soured on Trump from the
moment he was elected just as they have
with Biden by the way Biden actually had
a higher ranking among independents when
he was inaugurated like 61% and then it
plunged to 34 within six months um and
it it remains there so when we talk
about where Libertarians going to vote
um we have to I think um understand that
uh Libertarians at least for the last
three presidential elections they just
kind of vote libertarian I'm not sure
how much they know uh that there's all
these feuds within misis caucus and non-
mesis caucus there's lawsuits at the
state party level and all this kind of
stuff it might be something that
interest and it might also be something
they haven't even begun to hear about
and that they have just created their
own political identity as Libertarians
and if they see that word on a ballot
they go okay vote for that um so we
don't know my so my observation of the
very online Libertarians was a decent
amount of enthusiasm for v um I mean I
ran an inal poll on my Twitter so take
that for what it's worth and he was the
kind of you know plurality getter on uh
you know who is there like which
candidate would uh be most beneficial to
your personal Liberty um and it just
kind of confirmed what I've been seeing
a lot uh a bunch among a lot of online
Libertarians um now that fake is out uh
what do you make of that that VI love
among a certain segment of the
libertarian movement uh what do you
think a for it and where might it
go well I mean he wants it to go to
Donald Trump obviously he's now asking I
don't think it's going to necessarily um
well it's not that he has a a large
following to begin with you know he's
polling nationally like four or five uh
percent in a Republican primary the Iowa
uh the libertarian party did do like an
Iowa caucus thing there's a very small
number of votes but um pulled that up
too I'll pull that up uh Chase Oliver
got the most Chase Oliver that's an
underrated story right um in that uh
people have been talking about the misus
cockus Takeover and this and that and
the other Chase Oliver to my knowledge
and I haven't been following the lp very
closely so far this cycle he's not a
misus cockus guy that's not where he's
coming off like he's a two-time yeah
candidate who's pushed uh uh Democratic
Republican uh elections in Georgia into
runoffs twice um he seems to sort of
clean up and present pretty well as a
former military I believe um but that
poll is also interesting because vvec
ramaswami got four times as many votes
as Jacob hornberger uh Jacob hornberger
who last time was the runner up in the
libertarian party he was and he was also
the misus choice or at least the um by
you know compared to Joe Jorgenson and
she won uh kind of come from behind
Victory against Jacob hornberger uh this
could be just an outlier and it could
you know there was talk of that vvec
name got on that ballot through an odd
way to begin with um yes I saw some math
whz figuring out that uh if that those
like 1%
1.1% uh numbers represent like one vote
that about like 89 people voted in this
out of 99 counties so yeah so it's it
should be of salt but there are dozens
of us dozens dozens literal dozens uh VC
vivec says things that some people like
to hear which is that um you know
January 6 was an inside job and that the
election of 2020 is stolen of of course
that's in direct contradiction to what
he said about the 2020 election
literally 14 months ago which was that
people who are complaining that it's
stolen don't have any evidence and that
they're they the ones drinking copium uh
and that it's unseemly and they're
becoming the grand old party of
crybabies but you know whatever we all
we all change with new data I guess um
uh there are people who like that and
also like his very like bold provocative
ideas about foreign policy sort of a
radical semi anti-war or anti- us
intervention depending on how you look
at it type of things like he will
negotiate with Vladimir Putin to give
chunks of Ukraine uh to Russia in return
for making sure that Russia and China
don't cooperate and if they do break
that then Ukraine goes into NATO and I
guess there's an audience for that um
what do you make like that like what
like tear that argument apart for me
because it seems um a little bit Josh
Barrow has the Great Piece about I
believe it's Josh Barrow about how VC is
basically section guy um at any fancy
School you always see these people in
college the people who are always in a
hurry to raise their hand and they think
they know the answers to absolutely
everything and there's this um this ego
this narcissism the sense of hubris and
that they have all the answers to
everything when I look at VC's typically
Twitter posts on foreign policy that
talk about how actually he'll just solve
China uh and he'll just make it so Putin
and China
Cooper it always strikes me as I don't
know like a 19-year-old LARPing as a
foreign policy expert Matt you have way
more experience in this what do you make
of it just no president has the magic
want um and we should have learned that
from Donald Trump um of all things I
mean you know he was going to use the
magic wand to build wall or you know
extend the wall uh on the southern
border and it extended somewhat but the
magic W doesn't exist it's hard to get
stuff done and it's hardest of all to
get stuff done in the international
Arena so the less that you know about it
and the more that you're going in there
with Instinct rather or just you know a
feeling A vibe rather than knowledge of
how Powers interact with one another the
more that someone uh imagining uh magic
wand sounds great um and without and
without like a a backup plan I mean
we're living in a populist moment in the
United States and the globe and we have
been for about 10 years and there's a
lot of the part of that instinct is a
correct one in my view which is that the
way that the world is ordered um doesn't
have as much Democratic legitimacy it
seems to be happening regardless of
whether one wants it or not that's the
always the fertile ground for
conspiratorial thinking and I I use that
non-pejorative in this case um uh if
you're trying to figure out why this
policy or these conditions these
decisions keep happening and your vote
has nothing to do with it your your
attitudes have nothing to do with it
then you start developing some theories
uh about that because it seems like you
you are powerless I mean you see this a
lot in Western Europe for example
because the world order is something
that Western Europe hasn't had a lot of
influence on it's the United States that
pretty much has the most influence on it
and so the average French person is
going to think uh all kinds of
conspiratorial things about um how these
decisions get made and where and by who
um so vivec plays into that or like he
Taps into that I should say uh that
sentiment that feeling like if we just
withdraw from NATO and if we just do
this do this then something that has
never been uh thought of before can
happen um it's just naive it's not how
structures and parties work I I would
say like one way of thinking about it is
um uh is brexit Right brexit makes total
sense from just like a sovereignty kind
of point of view right um and the people
who were pushing brexit had all kinds of
very uh naive ideas about what would
happen afterwards um they actually
didn't have a very good plan for that
and then brexit's still kind of a big
mess afterwards and the results were not
what the people who were pushing for it
promised or wanted um it's a lot easier
to say you know to quote Steve Martin I
break with the I break with you and you
throw dog poop on somebody's shoes than
it is to build what replaces the post
World War II order um so if your
instinct is like well just that
order um then then vivc ramas Swami is
good and there's a lot of people who
have that instinct um and uh and would
rather just Express that than try to
construct what comes next I think the
the populism question is Central to
understanding kind of libertarianism
right now in 2023 we had this
conversation uh we went into this topic
with Dave Smith on the first episode of
the show um and I want to just play a
little bit of Dave's argu he's very much
in the propop pois camp and this is a
debate that stretches back to kind of
the beginnings of modern American
libertarianism um let's have I want to
have Dave articulate his case for
libertarian populism and then kind of
delve a little more deeply into this so
let's roll that
best I'm a big believer in the
rothbardian kind of like populist idea
that and look I think you see this with
Javier Malay right like this is the way
it can be done like this is the way to
do it is to tap into this this kind of
Pop streak particularly at a time when
the elites have so mismanaged everything
and kind of like talk to people about
how they're being ripped
off um so I think that got cut off a
little ear let's keep looks like it
froze there we go so um uh I mean what
what do you think of that uh that
argument that um you know at at the end
of the day there are uh there there is a
sort of you know
managerial elit or at
least people who have that ambition to
uh plan our society and that
Libertarians should be defining
themselves in opposition to that
agenda I think a lot of things about
that um one is that I should always
preface that uh my job uh or my
self-conception um uh is not about the
wielding of political the attainment or
the wielding of political power uh and
so when I uh am asked about you know how
should we attain and wield political
power I don't have great answers or at
least you should take them with all the
gray of salt my job is to do journalism
uh libertarian journalism um a lot of
that can be very righteous and angry and
froing and pointing out the just Brutal
mismanagement by the elite political
class it's a huge percentage of what we
do at reason uh and what I've done in my
life before and uh I ever worked for a
reason or really knew much about the
place um so it's part of it yeah but uh
also journalism is just a different
thing it's it's a it's Gathering of
facts I would point to if we're going to
be talking about Marie rothbard strategy
as being something that that is helpful
um you should point out that um it
wasn't always helpful the Marie rothbard
went to some bad places in the early
1990s um uh that is what happens when
you go towards the attainment of
political party and also power and also
like this sort of attempt and there's
something Elite about the this attempt
as well or at least not Elite it's it's
like uh it's a it's a Temptation that
intellectuals and people who work in the
knowledge class um all always are
tempted by which is that if I can just
harness this populist feeling out there
I'm going to produce my intellectual
ideological outcome um yeah you see this
with with Marie rothbard and Lou
Rockwell in the early 1990s with the
Roth Rockwell rothbard report uh they
were talking about Joe Senator Joe
McCarthy tail Gunner Joe as being a role
model they were saying nice things about
David Duke um they cozied up to Pat
Buchanan um at the time as a kind of
predictive element of where a segment of
the population was going to go as as a
sort of John the Baptist figures uh for
Donald Trump they were on to something
absolutely and they were on to something
much more than I certainly expected so
hats off for you know sort of like the
describing a a world as it exists rather
the world than I thought it was um but
as a a place where a person can go um
and uh and like and hold on to one's
libertarianism or one's ideology it was
corrupting those types of things are
corrupting uh it's going to lead you to
positions like Lou Rockwell had of like
defending the cops against Rodney King
of writing just really horrible things
like the the early 1990s stuff that came
uh whether it's in the Ron Paul
newsletters or the or the rothbard
Rockwell report and all these kind of
things it's it's very noxious it's very
anti-libertarian um uh it went to a bad
place uh and you could say that admiring
Ro uh rothbart for plenty of other
things that he contributed in his life
but he was always kind of a political
schemer um one way to look at this and
take rothbard and take libertarian
politics out of this for a second is um
look at the difference between what what
Chris rufo does and what uh for instance
the foundation for individual rights and
education does they are always at
loggerheads even though they frequently
have the same kind of uh opponents in
the world it's just a different approach
fire um uses a they're sort of Tethered
to a set of principles which they apply
hopefully uh and in my view U usually um
very consistently uh across time rufo is
is going towards power um political
power like Ronda santis in Florida and
trying to influence it I think both
approaches are valid by the way and I
think like absolutely Chris ruo has
influenced uh American policy and debate
more than a lot of private actors have
for a long time um but I think it's also
corrupting you're going to lead to bad
laws which I think some of that has
happened in Florida so um it's
libertarian Pop I think libertarian is
naturally populist in that sense it is a
a position from which you critique the
application of power and you correctly
identify that especially those people
who say that oh we're just over here
like trying to solve problems that that
is actually ideological even uh as much
or more ideologically or more
influentially ideological
than libertarianism is and yeah Javier
Malay going a a bunch and ripping stuff
off of a wall is awesome I would love to
see that as I would love to see someone
uh articulate in the way that he has in
those videos that we've all seen talking
about economics and just rapid fire
insane you know Nick gpie on on crank uh
kind of mode that's that's all thrilling
and exciting but let's also remember um
the conditions that brought him were so
horrible and I hope we don't live to see
them in this country what yeah and there
it's it's also it's also uh you know
targeted at a the from a Libertarian
perspective it's grounded we talked
about this with Dave too it's grounded
in libertarian Theory and he is when
he's you know saying AA and ripping
things off he's talking about
dismantling unnecessary government
bureaucracies which all of us in this
conversation agree with and like when I
think about populism um I I I agree
largely with saying Matt that there's a
sort of cynicism to Libertarians
embracing it uh because populism can
almost be its own uh ideology it's like
it is the belief that there is just that
that Elites um themselves are kind of
inherently bad and I think for
Libertarians it's like well no it's more
like people who are using their Elite
status to infringe on others Liberties
are bad like in in a free Society there
you know we would have you know
academics and we would have uh you know
Titans of industry and so like so there
there would be kind of like natural
Elite so we're not against that
necessarily but uh we're against Natural
Elites Zack Weiss meller well we're
we're against like uh you know the CLA
Schwabs of the world uh who is himself
defining uh
himself against libertarian he he said
you know Libertarians these anti-stem
people are the enemy um and so you know
I I have no problem being kind of like
creeped out by like the the dastardly
plans of the world economic Forum even
though I don't think that you know
they're they're out there you know
eating babies uh that but they they want
to they they they have a vision they
have the a kind of you know technocratic
vision of the world they have this this
idea that um you know we're we're going
to kind of meld uh public and private
and we're we're you know have we're
gonna have stakeholder capitalism we're
gonna kind of go the China model that
that is something to be alarmed about
and worried about and and to the degree
that you know resisting that is quote
unquote populism fine but this kind of
unored populism and and appealing to
just like a
an a vague sense of uh the elites are
are controlling everything I think that
is where we start to run into big
problems well wouldn't libertarian
populists counter to both of you because
I do want to sort of play devil's
advocate for a second here I think I
agree with what you guys are saying but
wouldn't the libertarian populist if one
were in the room with us
counter Zach they shut you inside your
house in Los Angeles for for you know a
a really long time to the point where
you felt the need to move your entire
family to Florida to ensure your kids
didn't grow up masked Matt you know same
for you in New York City I mean you have
basically been betrayed by the state
that has locked you inside your houses
for many months on end and basically
removed Public Schools as an option
available to your children what has the
state done for you and Liz and Liz they
blocked you from going to church right I
mean I mean legitimately people from
going to church that is such a
radicalizing notion I mean just cut off
they did all of this to us and then they
basically said you know Matt and Liz in
order to possibly enter a New York City
restaurant uh with your family you have
to show proof that you've gotten the
vaccine a bunch of times at a certain
point right because they required
multiple doses oh and then by the way
Zach those questions you had about the
origins of this whole virus and whether
or not there was a lab leak well
actually we're going to censor and
suppress a whole bunch of information
journalistic information that attempts
to get to the bottom of this even though
it's all happened in China you know
where the CCP sorry I did my best Donald
Trump ask China but like where the CCP
we know it's not generally transparent
with us right like so when you when you
tally up what they've done to us over
the last four or so years not to mention
every single year they take Hefty Hefty
chunks of our paychecks how could you
not hate the state like at a
certain well it's not yeah it's it's not
about that and let let me just give one
counter that and I I am curious to hear
Matt weigh in on this but you know when
you talk about they locked me down in
Los Angeles it was basically one person
named Barbara ferer who was the public
health authority for LA County who's
like a uh you know a master's of Public
Health or something like that and then
who was it that ultimately declared that
uh you know locking people out of their
churches was unconstitutional it was a
bunch of robed Elites from ivy league
from the ivy league uh sitting on the
Supreme Court so it's not as simple as
like the elites versus the non- elites
are are on your side or or not on your
side and and that's I guess my point is
like we should be looking more at what
is what are the mechanisms for these
infringements rather than like what kind
of strata of society or culture is it
coming from but I do think it is worth
pointing out that like Barbara Farrar
and you know Big City Mayors um whether
Garcetti or deasio were all taking their
cues from Anthony fouy and then the
teachers unions and Randy we Garten Who
Matt has written about extensively right
like to some degree there was a level of
uh coordination maybe not in the sort of
sense that people Envision of like well
the Deep state is conspiring against us
but there is certainly uh well the CDC
says one thing and Anthony fouy says one
thing and then all of these big City
Mayors take their cues from that and so
on and so forth Matt what do you make of
all this that um is I mean I've always
used the phrase political class in that
in in many cases and this is absolutely
true and it was an actual conspiracy in
that people met together and made
decisions I mean the the classic case is
the February
2021 new Biden Administration guidelines
at the CDC about distancing in in public
schools uh where the new uh CDC director
relle wilinsky made a recommendation
that was counter to her own personal
recommendation of the summer previously
when she was a private citizen uh
because um she had Randy wearden
president of the American Federation of
teachers in on those scientific
discussions and since a huge swath of
the country the one run by democrats for
the most part basically followed CDC
dictat on uh these things that meant
that sentenced kids to further time in
halftime
or remote schooling and there was a
Revolt uh that happened in Massachusetts
and elsewhere and they had to scramble
and revise those
calculations a month later um but it
showed that that thing was was corrupted
from from root and branch and yes the
the elites and this and I would include
here the journalistic class too as part
of the political class right now you
have a large swath of Journalism dumb
who are cheering on censorship by the by
Administration like we have to combat Co
misinformation and if that means you
know taking Joe Rogan off Spotify well
darn it that's just what we've got to do
it's insane um and we should have
contempt towards that um I would just
say in my own little hippie Corner over
here we just had Martin Luther King day
here and I'm always glad to see people
look up his various writings and
speeching about everything and and I've
always been I think the perhaps greatest
or certainly you know top five pieces of
American uh political writing and
rhetoric is letter from Birmingham Jail
which has the four steps essential steps
in his position or his his point of view
uh uh towards uh creating a nonviolent
campaign of uh of a non-violent um
resistance and uh two of those steps are
always uh kind of overlooked uh but one
of them is the uh Gathering of facts
right not fictions but facts the other
one is self-purification um which is to
say if your heart is filled with hate
you're going to do bad at at at doing
persuasive convincing protest so um I
have contempt for a lot of the actions
that you described Liz and even you
bringing them up again makes the blood
pressure kind of go up and and get all
prickly um I try not to be governed by
hate I don't think uh encouraging people
to hate the state is going to lead to
Great outcomes but that's just me
personally um and again I'm not in the
power wielding business um I know that
if I'm governed by hate uh of you know
the protesters blocking the Williamsburg
Bridge when I want to cross it um that
I'm probably going to get to some bad
policy ideas so I try to not do it you
know speak uh reflecting on that that
message of nonviolence for a second and
and how uh kind of important that is to
you um what one of the the political
predictions that you've publicly made
Matt is that there's going to be some
sort of political violence unfold in
this year um or and at least you're
you're worried that that's going to
happen um and part of that uh seems to
come down
to how people view what has transpired
in this country over the past four or
five years um
specifically you know the the Touchstone
there is January 6 and you you wrote a a
piece that I think drew a lot of fire
calling out V ramas Swami's comments on
January 6 let me pull that up here the
headline is V ramaswami really really
wants you to know he thinks January 6
was an inside job um and uh I
highlighted a passage from here this is
what V had to say about jary 6 there's
now clear evidence that there was at the
very least entament of peaceful
protesters similar to the fake Gretchen
Witcher Gretchen Whitmer kidnapping plot
the FBI won't admit how many undercover
officers there were in the field on
January 6 Capital police on one hand
fired rubber bullets and explosives into
a peaceful crowd who then then they
willingly later allowed to enter the
capital that doesn't add up if the Deep
state is willing to manufacture an
Insurrection to take down its political
opponents they can do anything once you
see it you can't unsee it what is
the fundamental problem with uh ramas
Swami's formulation there and what are
your worries about how this kind of
increasingly uh that that that if this
formulation is increasingly accepted or
or embraced by mainstream political
figures how how what effect um are you
worry that that's going to have on
American Civil Life that is not clear
evidence of inment or the manufacturer
of an Insurrection it is not it is not
that's not clear evidence of that um you
like show me the clear evidence it's the
beginning noting that there are um
there's been an admission that at least
a handful of FBI informants were uh in
the field that day um and that's by the
FBI uh in hearings over the summer um uh
noting that is not clear evidence it is
the beginning of of a series of
questions um and those questions then
should lead you to where uh the next
place that you would find evidence for
this especially if you're going to say
that this is very similar to the
Gretchen Whitmer kidnapping uh in which
like so many cases after 911 the FBI had
people uh like uh people who were
pretending to be people that they were
not not just informants not just sort of
like uh like saying hey these guys over
here are doing it they were hooking up
the plot themselves to kidnap gret and
Whitmer a plot that was never going to
happen it's private among a small group
of uh somewhat gullible people uh we've
seen this over and over again we've
written about this over and over again
at reason including back uh long before
Vic ramas Swami uh expressed any
interest in the subject in any kind of
public way um so uh the next place that
you would look in a place like gret and
Whitmer is like okay um is testimony
from those people's part of the charging
documents in the case um is it part of
the criminal conviction when it goes to
trial in those entrapment cases they
were and that is typically how that goes
that's how we learn about it that's how
in the case of Michigan uh some of those
charges were thrown out although they
were then retried um in the
889 convictions that have happened uh
related to the January 6 riots Capital
Hill uh 200 of which involved violent
activity um there has been zero
cases as far as we know as far as I'm
aware of um in which that showed up in
the charging documents and that was part
of the trial testimony evidence from
Agents provocators informants in the
field um so if this is clear evidence it
would show some fingerprints somewhere
unless uh I'm still holding out the
possibility here in general like we
should suspect the FBI having a default
suspicion and a deep one is yeah totally
fine so then where do you look so the
way that that uh you can imagine that
this was um uh that we wouldn't need to
use that testimony that could have been
there is just by simply um that the
actions of the people um you know
charging through barricades uh causing
injury to more than 100 Capital police
um that their actions alone were enough
to convict them but that should lead you
to and so therefore they didn't need
this testimony even though they could
have totally done it but that should
lead you to another conclusion which is
to say the way that you avoid that kind
of entament and let's remember that
since I wrote that article thec has now
called January 6 um entrapment day um
the way to avoid entrapment is to not uh
bust through barricades and break
windows and fight with capital police
officers while trying to enter the
Capitol Building um on the day that
they're supposed to be certifying the
presidental election you could totally
avoid it by not doing any of those
things and I don't say that CH and I
don't say that in a way to be like
high-fiving these grossly long sentences
of various proud boys members I don't
think that the Insurrection um uh the
Sedition charges I I don't think that
that those were appropriate I think
they're way too long um I agree with
viac ramaswami that people who are
nonviolent shouldn't be serving prison
for their activities on that day um I
agree with him um so uh but it's not
clear evidence of entrapment it just
isn't and uh and he also said that the
capital police are just the same as the
FBI no they're not they're different
they're actually different organizations
um and if the capital police and the
other two things that he's pointing to
as as clear bits of evidence were like
well look um they you know they did tear
gas and Weber Bullets Over Here although
very small amounts um um but they let in
you barricades over here so look they're
just like letting them right in that
doesn't add up well it's a chaotic scene
if you have a if you anyone who has been
in a riot knows that it doesn't add up
riots are crazy moments like everyone is
acting in strange ways and if the
Capitol Hill Police were in on it that
means that they ushered in first of all
that means that all of the interviews
that have been done with them they all
managed to just sort of like um uh be
completely disciplined about not
spilling the beans on the worst day in
the history of the Capitol Police
they're like okay we'll just totally
swallow this conspiracy it's hard a
single whistleblower yeah how people
would be in cahoots for all of this to
add up right like it would have to be
hundreds and hundreds of people who've
all perfectly synced up their stories
with not a crack in sight and not even
anybody privately sort of admitting to
their groups of friends what's what
right I I do want to get to to the
beginning of Zach's question which is
yeah um because it's not one-sided it's
not just January 6th is my uh worry
about violence the way that I'm worried
about violence related to January 6 is
that it is clear that the Republican
party uh the mainstream of the
Republican party is not taking
responsibility for January 6th um uh
like clear majorities when you poll
Republicans either blame it like on
antifa or the FBI or Ray EPS or whoever
is in their imagination who did it um or
they say yeah it's fine um like it's
Justified because Biden stole the
election so like that's not taking
responsibility for Human Action at all
you have to like own the agency of it
one way or the other in my estimation or
else you are basically intellectually
greenlighting further violence and on
the left that is the same um in
different ways but that overall Dynamic
is the same with the 2020 post George
Floyd riots which killed you know 14 19
people I forget the the exact huge
amounts of damage and not just that but
Portland was on fire for a 100
consecutive days people were just like
uh you know besieging and throwing human
uh at the uh police building in
Downtown Portland over and over they're
just burning stuff day after day we
boarded up New York City Manhattan which
I don't think is a trump uh a you know a
big Trump supporting region we put
plywood on Windows here because we
assumed that if Trump won the people who
didn't like him would Riot so that says
to me that we've normalized a lot of
political violence and the post October
7th demonstrations which I mentioned
before which do irritate me to great
effect because it it keeps me from
getting home uh and that's that's just
no good um if we're allowing small
groups of raggedy ass protesters to
close Bridges to uh prompt the
evacuation of the White House which
happened the other day um that says to
me that we haven't thought we haven't
come up with a plan on what to do if you
uh behavior that gets rewarded gets
repeated in the famous formulation and
so if that all it takes is a couple of
beardies and some college dropouts to
block a bridge that well that seems fun
let's block O'Hare Airport let's SN the
worst thing is that they're not College
dropouts they in fact graduated from
their liberal arts schools and now want
uh loan forgiveness from the rest of us
so uh you know it's important to note
that but I I do also I I was confused by
the boarding up of Windows all up and
down Fifth Avenue um on Election Day uh
this past go around as well especially
because one of the things that was most
striking to me was that Sleep Number The
Mattress Store was boarded up and I'm a
little bit like were you seriously
expecting the Looting of mattresses um
in Manhattan like how exactly was that
going to go like please play this out
for me but you get tired and like from a
long night of rioting and need a little
rest but I think your point is well
takeen and I think it you your writing
on this actually kind of at least shakes
me out of this mindset where since this
has just been the state of play for the
last I don't know frankly since 2020
Summer of 2020 post George Floyd it was
very much
normalized but even before that a little
bit we saw Zack and I were just talking
recently about all of the um you know
Carnage in Ferguson Missouri and
basically how that was sort of you know
obviously there have been different
waves of protests La in the 90s is
another good example that you mentioned
earlier there have been these waves of
protests and riots that have popped up
but to some degree I kind of feel like
from 2014 and then we had a little pause
when things were kind of good and decent
from 2016 to 2020 and then 2020 up until
now these eras where it feels like small
groups of people exerting extraordinary
influence
um and really affecting other people's
abilities to live their lives uh people
you know shopkeepers abilities to
actually uh earn a living for themselves
people's abilities to go out their
business unmolested it's kind of
increasingly rare and it's it's
important to kind of whip our head snap
our heads out of this and remember
living in such a politically tumultuous
era is not a normal thing this is not
aspirational this is not good this is
not how every single era has totally
been though obviously there have been
these waves of it but at least for the
last four years the fact that this is at
least to me feels like a fact of life is
a hugely problematic thing where it does
like political violence is sort of
increasingly um it's like we
increasingly act like if it's for the
right cause it's no big deal and
actually it's really important to say no
no matter the cause it's a really
big deal yeah I think that's the
key point is that the the excusing of it
but that
and the cowardice from political leaders
to condemn political violence uh if it's
coming from your side more or less that
that's what we're what Matt is
describing with January 6 that's what we
saw with these riots and uh that that
denying of uh personal agency which I
would think is something that
Libertarians would be particularly
attuned to and and able to recognize
like the importance of agency and
responsibility but I I do think it's
becoming an increasingly unbridgeable
divide among Libertarians uh and other
small government types who more or less
believe what ramaswami says about
January 6 and the leadup to it and those
of us who think there's there might be
some shadiness there might have been
some egging on but don't see the
evidence of some massive setup and
that's not even to say that the Entre
Insurrection framing or narrative is
exactly right either I I just think
there's a there's a lot of contributing
factors and and blame to go around which
you could trace all the way back to if
you wanted the beginnings of the Trump
Administration and the Russia
investigation and the the the discontent
uh I think a lot of it of legitimate
about how that was handled the
outrageous the the the lies and the bad
policy around covid the media the the
political hypocrisy and defenses of
looting it's that it's all a valid
discussion but if one of us believes
that January 6 was a manufactured plot
to stop us from discovering the truth
and the other just doesn't see the
evidence for that it's it's such a
different view of reality and I just
wonder like can can people that that
have those two different views even
really be in a IAL Coalition together
sure sure um I mean part part of me
hears you uh in the sense that you know
uh I try to figure out what's going on
and and I will confess to occasionally
writing with at least a little bit of
mild irritation when I chase down
someone's uh statement down a rabbit
hole and like really spend a long time
to try to figure out whether it's true
and discover that there's that it's just
based on not much I did that like a nine
months ago when RFK Jr was saying that
basically Trum Tucker Carls was bounced
off Fox because he took on big Pharma um
and uh and you know I wrote a thing that
no one cared about um like going into it
just because it was so frustratingly
wrong um and and indicative of a of a of
a different mindset and yet Zack Weiss
Miller I think you should smoke more pot
like Liz wolf does and um that you know
there's always unbridgeable divides like
60% of Americans including Jacob hmer I
think he's written like a couple of
books on this uh leading libertarian
Party candidate uh believe that there is
a JFK uh conspiracy um uh beyond that
you know the Communist guy shot him um
and uh I don't but does that mean I
can't agree with Jacob horenberger and
maybe you know would I vote for him if
he's on my H ballot in New York I would
yeah I would vote for Jacob for is that
a totally different situation because
that's like one discreet long ago
example no as opposed to this like
massive political undercurrent this
political thing that's still happening I
get what you're saying I'm just I'm like
people you could have like used the
phrase unbridgeable divide in the 1970s
to describe so very damn much the 70s as
bad as what we're having now and as as
like as many palpitations as I feel
about I think the inevitable deadly
political violence of this year and and
political violence is just it it is more
traumatic than than apolitical violence
um uh not necessar to the people who
experienc it but to the country at large
because you could sort of see it coming
out when the proud boys and antifa are
engaging in Street battles as happened
throughout the Trump Administration not
just in 2020 um there's something that's
you know the idea of like a street
political street gangs we're right to be
freaked out by that but uh the 70s were
worse by a lot there was just hijackings
and bombings like on a daily basis that
were very explicitly political and what
happened to a lot of those people who
were just like they went Bonkers just
joining The Weather Underground um doing
like the very schismatics between in the
Black Panther Party just like a lot of
just murdering going on people kind of
like eventually went jogging by the late
70s and like came out of it as College
professors and they stopped murdering
people and doing bombs and hijackings uh
people are able to come out of it and
there's always going to be in and I've
said this many times um and and and I
never mean this pejoratively again but
in marginal political movements and this
is sort of just a description of its
existence within the mainstream and
libertarianism is marginal in that sense
um it's going to attract marginal people
people who believe all kinds of
interesting weird things and I am one of
those people I am marginal um and there
are things that I believe that are crazy
I'm sure of it um like so
um I have a whole conspiracy related to
Bob Woodward that I'm not uh at Liberty
to uh
discuss at large flight 800 too I'm
pretty big on that one too um uh yeah
you bet um but uh no like it just
there's going to be people who tend
toward the conspiratorial bent within
the libertarian camp that doesn't mean
that I cannot break bread with them and
agree with them on ad hoc basis of
things I'm again not in I'm not
organizing a Libertarian political party
here um I don't uh I I'm so like I don't
get as uh as frustrated as you sound
with the uh sense of the UN unbridgeable
divide I just take it as a given that my
little thread of the world is going to
be a very very lonely place and uh and I
also don't care what anyone thinks about
I mean I guess part of my frustration is
that I would like to see libertarianism
move from the margins um and it seemed
for a while that there was some momentum
to that uh to that end um and you know I
I want us to to get you know a a serious
uh movement before we get to the point
of you know needing a a wild hobby a
Malay to swoop in because we we don't
like like you said before we don't want
to ever get to that point where where we
need to where we're dealing with triple
digit inflation and kind of just like
rampant political corruption um it but
but like as I was wondering this this
question of like where is the
libertarian movement right now and like
where are they going to settle uh in
terms of candidates or you know and like
are Libertarians even going to matter in
this election um one thing that was that
popped out uh to me that that was
interesting was this video that uh Rand
Paul put out who's an avatar of a
certain kind of libertarianism and he
wouldn't commit to any candidate but he
will commit to being never Nicki which
is uh never Nikki Haley which is kind of
interesting to me in itself that like he
that he won't land anywhere but he can
Define himself as against something so I
want to play just a a a short bit from
his never Nicki video and then ask you
to react to the message that Rand Paul's
putting out there let's roll that
good morning everyone as I told you
yesterday I'm ready to say something
about the presidential race I've had a
long relationship with Donald Trump and
there's a lot to like there I'm also a
big fan of a lot of the fiscal
conservatism of Ronda santis I think V
ramas Swami has been an important voice
also have listened to and met with the
independent Bobby Kennedy I'm not yet
ready to make a decision but I am ready
to make a decision on someone who I
cannot support so I'm announcing this
morning that I'm never Nicki I don't
think any informed or knowledgeable
libertarian or conservative should
support Nikki Haley I've seen her
attitude towards our invent our
interventions overseas I've seen her
involvement in the military-industrial
complex $8 million being paid to become
part of the team but I've also seen her
indicate that she thinks you should be
registered to use the internet that
people posted ideas anonymously I think
she fails to understand that our
Republic was founded upon people like
Ben Franklin Sam Adams Madison John Jay
and others who posted routinely for fear
of the government they posted routinely
anonymously and I think her failure to
really understand that or to think that
you should register through the
government somehow for the internet is
something that should disqualify in the
minds of all libertarian libertarian
leaning
conservatives so um I mean that's not
very hard for me to get on board with
the the rationale is pretty sound from
from my perspective but what what do you
think of uh what Rand Paul's putting out
there Matt totally agree with him about
uh in the critique of Nikki Haley for
her bonker's idea about everyone
registering online um we already have
enough of a problem right now with
bipartisan censoriousness especially as
it involves technology it's just a crazy
thing she keeps repeating it and it's
bad um yeah also vivec ramas Swami wants
to ban Tik Tok from existing um and
Robert F Kennedy Jr has threatened the
corporate death penalty over any number
of organizations including the
competitive Enterprise Institute so I'm
not sure how we're exempting exempting
especially RFK Jr uh given his track
record from uh you know uh saying what
Libertarians should and shouldn't vote
for which again is not my game but I'm
not an elected Senator um I think it's
interesting um uh what Ram Paul did uh
and has done and what Mike Lee has also
done Mike Lee before the Iowa caucus uh
endorsed Donald Trump and I'm old enough
to remember the 2016 convention which I
covered in which I spent a lot of time
in the hit pocket of Mike Lee um he was
the leading voice of opposition to
Donald Trump at the 2016 convention uh
just screaming and yelling at Donald
Trump this whole Utah delegation
situation that went down and then in
October of 2016 after the uh Hollywood
uh what's it what's it called whatever
the grabbing by the uh stuff um
came out Hollywood clip Access Hollywood
thank you um uh Mike Ley was again a
leading voice of disgust I could never
vote for someone who would ever say
anything like that to any woman under
any circumstance um and so to watch him
uh in this year uh before uh the primary
uh election before the Iowa caucus say
I'm going to vote for Donald Trump
because he delivers on his promises and
you know that's more important than Mean
Tweets um uh I don't think that is I
think I find that to be a much less
serious argument than what Rand just put
forth um although on some level both of
them are engaged in the same thing which
is to exist as a senator in
2024 as a Republican senator um uh you
need to uh probably be on board with
Donald Trump much more than that was the
case in we forget it right now but
something like 11 uh sitting US senators
in 2016 did not endorse Donald Trump uh
against Hillary Clinton um uh they uh
sat on their hands or withdrew their
endorsements that they had given before
mostly because the Access Hollywood tape
but some for other reasons as well um
you can't you can no longer basically do
that Mitch McConnell is one of the only
people who's been sitting on his hands
so far in this uh election the
Republican party has come around if you
wish to exist as those people that's
what you have to do uh so if you are a
Libertarian leaning politician in power
you are going to find a way to
accommodate Donald Trump and one easiest
way to do that is to say that Nikki
Haley is bad on war um I think that
Nikki Haley is uh sees uh uh you know an
Access of Evil around every corner uh I
think many of those people who are in
her proped Access of Evil are also evil
um so uh but her ideas about what to do
about that are going to be different
than mine um uh for me and I'm not a
Libertarian Senator libertarian is
Republican senator uh for me how Donald
Trump behaved in the runup to and on
January 6th is self-evidently
disqualifying I could never imagine any
circumstances which to vote for him but
again as mentioned before I presume that
I am on a very lonely Little Island here
um and that Ram Paul has his finger on
the pulse of mainstream America more
than I do I am intrigued by the idea of
uh this sort of negatively defining like
like could we could Libertarians settle
on someone by process of elimination or
like via negativa like uh for Haley it's
like you know uh online speech check uh
Warhawk check that's off the list uh
Trump um you know acting like a maniac
on January 6 and many other things check
uh and like it's
the the the process of elimination
towards a Libertarian candidate I I I
wonder if that's something uh more
politicians could consider and I it also
makes yeah go ahead here's the thing
that I was thinking about uh earlier
this morning and last night in Long
preparation for my grilling by the the
two of you uh which is what are Donald
Trump's libertarian
accomplishments seriously what are they
um I so Federal Regulation cutting right
uh so that's that is the one and it is a
mixed record at at best um because uh in
addition to cutting regulations and I
wrote a cover story about this in 2017
um far you cut regulation far more than
than uh his biggest deregulatory
supporters thought possible but then he
also regulated um you know uh like when
you when you choke off immigration turns
out that's actually a regulation uh uh
those trade rules those are
regulatory people would also point to
appointing Betsy dooso and some of the
title 9 overhaul as well as well as um
also Supreme Court appointments Supreme
cour uh yeah but
Gorsuch
um we've that's something that you know
lasts uh you know generation so we've
got
2.5 we've got 2.5 libertarian accomplish
M I think and and I agree with the uh
the Betsy DeVos very much it didn't I
mean she was good in that position
really amount to that much especially
the title The Title Nine was you were
right to point to the Title Nine that
was an that was an a a complete uh
Victory although Biden is it was undone
right so what does it really matter
there wasn't an enduring impact it was
sort of valuable for four years and then
poof right I think um one of the things
that you see a lot of elected Republican
libertarian leaning Trump supporters big
mouthful there point two is Donald Trump
on foreign policy and I think the funny
thing about that is that it wasn't
Donald Trump who withdrew from
Afghanistan it was Joe Biden um and
regardless of how you think he did it
and I don't think anyone thinks he did
it particularly well um and if you look
I think this an early suspicion at least
Mike Lee said um that uh you know I'll
take his uh fulfilling promises over uh
over Mean Tweets I think Mean Tweets
are in many senses people's sense of his
accomplishments right like if people
talk about if an anti-war libertarian
talks about Donald Trump uh chances are
they're going to mention his speech in
the 2016 Primary in South Carolina where
he like absolutely trashed the entire
Bush family um as being like
particularly great and it was
particularly great it was mean it was
wrong and stuff like like on manners
level but as just like calling out an
entire wing of foreign policy
in the United States and the Republican
party it was kind of righteous and
awesome it's also basically a mean tweet
it doesn't like how did that change he
didn't start a new big war that's great
neither is Biden um uh but that's also
like a a non- negative accomplishment I
think people actually like it his insult
comedy and see that as an accomplishment
or at least something that they can
affiliate with because it drives his
enemies insane um and that the
establishment
the thrill yeah are you surprised that
um you know Ronda santis has not uh
attracted more libertarian interest
because yes he has these uh you know
this odd speaking style and these
overboard um social policies in Florida
but also he was the anti-lockdown
governor he uh you know Florida I can
attest is governed fairly well at least
compared to California where I left um
and you know we did a whole issue on
kind of some of the attributes of
Florida in reason magazine
um why do you think like are
Libertarians sleeping on Des Santa I
think there was a lot of initial
enthusiasm and let's not forget Thomas
Massie endorsed him early right um uh
and um and I'm kind of surprised that
more people didn't but there isn't
really a your list of libertarian
leading Republicans Runs Out out pretty
quickly um and uh some of the few who
existed uh have long since exited the
scene like Justin deos uh like Jeff
Flake from Arizona um uh and uh and
others um so uh I think that if DeSantis
would have run more strenuously on his
Co record I mean even in his terrible
debate with Gavin Newsome not saying
that he was particularly terrible Al
though he wasn't great in that debate
but the whole thing was just kind of
really dispiriting and awful that should
be such a layup for for for Ronda santz
it shouldn't be close it was like there
even indicated that it should be a layup
because at at one point Newsome was
almost attempting to hang DeSantis on
his own record right like Newsome was
sort of like you know saying that he was
that DeSantis was insufficiently you
know letting Florida be insufficiently
free from lockdowns and it's like well
wait a second How Could You Gavin Nome
possibly be saying this right to some
degree it was like new Sim's entire
debate strategy was evidence of how
Americans broadly now look at lockdowns
as a serious mistake right but I think
what Dan santis did um when he became a
national candidate and being conscious
of and let's remember he was within 15
percentage points of Donald Trump one
year ago was 45 to 30 and he looked like
he had the wind at his sales he went
culture War he went Disney and that's
what he was advertising himself to
National conservatives it wasn't
necessarily his covid record and what
that would and what his Co record taught
him about stuff like parental rights or
the intractability of teachers unions or
whatever um it was like we are going to
go after you know bug Light the national
conservatives who just openly hate
Libertarians so it's like yeah what yeah
I mean uh I don't I don't know um
desantis's own uh uh feeling about the
libertarian uh mini quadrant either but
uh I I don't think that that was a
particularly wise strategy it's also
possible and you hear this now from
disantis and sort of the the pre-
postmortem that are coming out that like
there's nothing he could have done um
but I found myself in the uh the
DeSantis Newsome debate um as someone
who absolutely is on desantis's Corner
in uh the comparative CID record and
think that that's like significant in
important I was wishing uh that Nikki
Haley was the one defending it uh just
she's been a better candidate for the
most part she's kind of like not had a
great last debate and and she didn't
really wasn't very impressive in in Iowa
uh in Her speech but like uh she has run
a much better public campaign has been
more convincing as someone delivering
Bon Ms uh and such um he just hasn't
been very good at this so I think it's a
combination of of going towards the
wrong thing and then just being in the
sort of impossible position of you know
I want to run against Trump and I'm
aware that it's Trump's party so how do
I deal with that like the the the
cognitive dissonance that that requires
uh seem to wear more heavily on him than
it does on Nikki Haley so I spent a lot
of time um psycho analyzing both of you
um you know whenever I get a minute to
myself and I was thinking Zach as you
were talking earlier about uh
libertarian beliefs you know being
pretty marginal but this enduring hope
that you have that they will move you
know into the mainstream I was thinking
about the degree to which you sort of to
some degree like came of age in Ron Paul
Revolution times is that sort of roughly
correct broad Strokes wise I I I don't
know about came of age but I would say
that would be politically activating
yeah yeah it was a politically
activating moment for you sure sure um
came into a certain political
Consciousness then um but Matt you had a
weird origin story to being a
Libertarian um depending on who you talk
to you kind of ended up sort of
gallivanting around central eastern
Europe for quite a while there and
Reporting basically on the fall of
Communism for uh many years how many how
many years were you in Prague eight and
or like eight in the region uh four four
in Prague one in Bratislava and three in
Budapest and it's postc communism it's
the 90s so likeing give us your sort of
superhero origin story that way I can
psychoanalyze you even better in the
future how did this sort of make you
libertarian is and what did that look
like and how does that make you think
about things differently than the rest
of us
weirdos
um could go a long time on that subject
I would say I mean I always I always uh
hated communism I'm a cold war baby uh
and then when you see the after effects
up close of of the absolute like whole
of
society um like murderous damage that
that does uh to the environment uh you
know which is something that people tend
to forget um to the the the educational
establishment to the minds of everybody
like it just is so destructive chze
Slovakia was a much more totalitarian
place than than late 80s Hungary where
also lived that goulash communism which
was softer but it was just it is so
incredibly distorting and awful and um
and then also fell into the sway of the
writings and activities of vatslav hav
who is behind me on my wall here on Orly
on that door um uh who writing about uh
politics and philosophy and
anti-communism and totalitarianism are
just really inspiring he's sort of like
a combination of George Orwell and and
Martin Luther King in some way there's a
lot of similarities and cross influences
of all of these characters and he talked
a lot about living within the truth or
living in truth and like the power of
that um uh in a sort of society or
system based on lies it's just very
inspiring and interesting one way that
it affects me to this day or at least
informs my understanding of Donald Trump
which might seem a little strange um is
that in the postcommunist kind of
wreckage there arose a series of
politicians um some of whom I covered
really closely like Vladimir mear in
Slovakia and uh uh who became the sort
of like uh crude hilarious nationalists
railing against Elites in foreign
capitals Davos man um off times it would
be sort of New York and Jerusalem or New
York and Tel Aviv and uh and Budapest is
where the bad people were coming from
and Brussels um but like uh railing
against the far-off elites always
railing against George Soros who had an
outside influence on those places in
developing the Civil Society um and it
was fascinating to watch them not just
about their own actions but about the
self-defeating
reaction to those people by the elites I
I can't tell you the number I can't
because it's probably just like six
because there weren't that many of us
covering Slovakia and its first years of
independence from Czechoslovakia in 93
and 94 but covering mear once we saw
Trump arise we all just emailed each
other like can you believe it it
happened in our country like people
because part of what they do is they go
and they are better at democracy than
the people who are trying to defend
democracy by opposing them by which I
mean they're just better politicians
Donald Trump has an incredible sway he's
incredible on on the on on the stump if
you can't recognize that he's absolutely
Ely hilarious regardless of how much you
hate him then you're missing a big story
in American politics and he's courting
that overreaction from people he wants
to say not just like go up to the line I
once interviewed Metar and he was about
ready to go to America to visit Clinton
although it wasn't a state sponsored
sanction visit I'm like what do you hope
to accomplish he's like I want to show
Americans that I don't eat children and
uh that and that I could use a fork and
knife and it's like that's funny like
it's he might be an authoritarian
leading kind of guy but it's kind of
funny um and so the so many Elites back
then that I would talk to including
people who would had been partnered up
with him and served in his government
until the very last minute and then they
said oh my God he's the worst ever very
similarly to all the Trump people do
they're like well you know he's always
going to get the votes out there in the
countryside but what do you expect those
people are old and stupid um uh it's
this like you have to actually beat
Donald Trump and people like that in by
doing democracy not by like finding some
extra uh like uh uh Democratic means
some shortcuts to dealing with him and
people were always looking for Amendment
perhaps 14th Amendment like let's let's
get him off this ballot let's try to
disqualify him this way um uh it's let's
kick him off Twitter and then he'll
start his own social media company and
still get his crazy message out like
seriously people were always like if we
could shut down this newspaper or start
that television station or take over
this media then finally we can get
through to those stupid people and like
no and you see the same kind of dumb
conversations about journalism In
America which again I thought I would
never see in my lifetime journalism when
I was coming up a thousand years ago was
was understood to be kind of um sort of
anti-authoritarian in its mindset uh at
least I deluded myself into believing so
and now it's just like openly censorious
and people are policing each other over
the adjectives that they use to talk
about Trump um just kind of awful so
that shaped my thinking yes Liz wolf um
uh in looking at this uh I had hoped
that I wouldn't see it in this country
because there's something kind of toddy
about going down the Metar Victor Orban
path uh and it's just amazing to me that
Victor orbon again someone I've covered
since the 90s has become a load star for
conservatives in America like wow
congratulations man um uh why do they
have crushes on Victor orbon is there
something seductive about him that I am
perhaps
missing misguided no that I mean they
they're seductive about like he rails
against Brussels so centralized
Authority he rails against NATO a lot of
people are are uh are are you know
falling out of love with NATO uh in the
Trump talk to me about NATO mattw I'm
not look don't don't French goodbye me
here wolf um uh he and he and he railed
against immigration he said I I don't
want immigration policy to be set by
Angela Merkel and he's kind of right
about that um regardless of what you
think about what they their immigration
policy should be um one it makes sense
to have a country be in charge of its
own immigration policy and it's kind of
weird that you would you would Outsource
that he's also super corrupt Hungary
also has gone from being the leader of
the pack on uh postcommunist economic
growth and GDP per capita to being one
of the worst just an abysmal uh record
of uh uh in the economy he's taken over
and and like a strong armed to various
churches um he's really Consolidated
power Rewritten the Constitution crack
down on media done a bunch of stuff uh
that objectively sucks and I have
pointed this out several times to
conservatives and they honestly don't
care and part of them just wants to do
that and you look at Trump there's a a
lot of Will To Power too and I presume
if he wins election you will see him
follow through on some of for example
his threats to sick the Department of
Justice or the uh or the uh FTC against
media companies in direct retaliation
for their behavior he said something
like that just yesterday um but I he has
much more chance of pulling things like
that off the conservatives um especially
the ones who are uh populist anti-elite
conservatives like Chris rufo and like
Ronda santis in a way they want to they
have a desire to wield government power
um against those institutions there's a
thirst out there for that Victor Orban
does that so that's what they like about
Victor orbon they see him as successful
for that and then some of the more
diluted ones like Rod Dreer believe that
he's like the last voice protecting the
West as if Hungary is like the Bastion
of Christianity which is absolutely
insane and self-d deluded what's the
thing that will disabuse some of these
conservatives of the notion that Victor
orbon uh is creating the promised
land
uh visiting any uh place in Hungary
that's not called Budapest probably
Budapest is super delightful
Cosmopolitan Jewish uh increasingly
thankfully um city I say that just
because their Community have been so Des
deated in World War II and elsewhere and
it's nice to see even though um orbon
and people like him have flirted with uh
kind of a rehabilitation of explicitly
anti-semitic characters from Hungarian
history um that there's been a
flourishing of the Jewish community in
Budapest it's also the best part of town
the that District but um uh it's great
it's super Cosmopolitan and you go there
like my God why can't everything be like
this well it's because you actually hate
cities like this in America you know
like Tucker Carlson giving architectural
lessons about about Budapest is just
it's objectively hilarious your Insight
about uh Budapest and then the
countryside reminds me a little bit of
something that I was paying attention to
last year when I was in Bucharest which
is different than Budapest you dumb
people uh if you in fact confuse them no
not actually um and I was thinking in
Romania about Bucharest and how you know
Matt you wrote about this I think in the
mids like flourishing movie scene movie
production uh industry there really
interesting I was noticing this past
time um you know a flourishing of the
restaurant scene a lot of immigrants
from other parts of Europe coming in and
opening up really really interesting
Foods obviously Romanian food has sort
of you know is is not really something
to write home about and has under chesu
is sort of you know took on less
prominence and there were some issues
with food shortages and such so the
Romanian food SE never really developed
but now immigrants are coming in and
really restoring a lot of that so you
look at actual Bucharest and its thrive
and it's Cosmopolitan and yeah there's
some ugly brutalist communist
architecture still but it's lovely and
then you go 30 minutes outside into the
countryside and it's just fullon rust
Bel people with decaying teeth kind of
everywhere right
like literal covered wagons and yeah and
uh and Kami housing factories and blocks
that are totally in rubble like exactly
and it's sort of a little bit of this
like well wait a second I could
understand how you could emerge from in
you're telling buest and in my telling
Bucharest if you'd only been in those
places with a certain sense of oh this
must be how this country is run this
must be you know these countries have
just recovered wonderfully and
Leadership is currently absolutely
excellent and it's like well surely if
you see anything outside of that little
tiny sample size your view begins to get
pretty complicated so I'm sort of
curious about like will the rod dryers
of the world like is is that sort of
part of the problem like did we diagnose
it or are we missing something
yes um I I would also um uh and and like
Budapest has a bigger div every country
has a you know country mouse City Mouse
situation but but like I think the next
largest Budapest has two million people
and the next largest city has like
300,000 I think um and that's similar to
uh Cuba uh and not many other countries
usually there's like there isn't such a
huge split so that's going to create all
kinds of weirdnesses that are pretty
significant Romania it's a little bit
more spread out I would just add um for
those there might be some people who are
sort of anti-interventionist anti- us
interventionists who think that Victor
orbon is a hero um uh you need to think
that one through uh because um one of
the things that he did it's one of the
single most
destabilizing uh acts to peace in the
world by a democratically elected leader
over the last 20 years is that he gave
voting rights to ethnic hungarians who
live to five million ethnic hungarians
who live outside the borders I don't but
it affects five Millions but there's
five million the immediate surroundings
um and you don't have to have been born
in Hungary so ethnic hungarians and like
if you look at the history of of Europe
over the last uh 100 years it's not real
great for what happens when a country uh
decides to uh give special rights to its
Ur while uh citizens who aren't even
their citizens in neighboring countries
that is a recipe for unrest and you're
seeing it um with the Hungarian minority
in Ukraine um and uh also in uh Serbia
and in Slovakia it's it's super not
great um so if you like him for anti-war
reasons um you should think that one
through
too well with that I want to thank you
for talking to us Matt Welch we so
appreciate having you on where can
people find you uh at reason.com uh
check out the reason Round Table podcast
you well know on Twitter Matt Welch as
well wonderful not mat
Walsh thanks for listening to just
asking questions these conversations
appear on reason's YouTube channel and
Facebook page every Thursday and the
just asking questions podcast feed every
Friday subscribe wherever you get your
podcast and please rate and review the
show whose voic is